me Josh and our homie Sam
we're getting ice cream uh then there
was there was a part of the day where um
he had a dookie okay I'm out I'm out and
you brother but he had a dookie okay
we're in line we went to this ice cream
place two times in a row because the
second time we were there two times in a
row like he went there and then you just
came back out the exit and then two
nights okay okay so we're there we're
there for night too okay
um day two of ice cream day two yes and
we're in line and we ate a bunch of food
prior and Josh is like dude
oh man I I think I got a dump
and then uh
they're like the line was pretty long to
get to the bathroom and there's a door
code on it okay Josh is feeling
unconscious he's like God because it's
like one of those single bathrooms
that's next to the line okay in place
and so we're in line and then uh
just we're getting close to the door and
then Alina goes hey Josh it's vacant if
you want to use it it's like you
[__]
so we get a little closer and Elena's
like just try to open it see if you
don't need the code and he goes to open
it it makes the loudest like
and then he's like [__] and then our
buddy Sam's like yo what's the code of
the door my boy has to take a [__] right
now
in front of the line and then the girl
goes one two three four five six and
Josh is like of course
enjoy your poop yeah y'all check them
out on YouTube by the way oh we've got a
great Channel then dude you got in there
I waited like three minutes and I just
started knocking on the car like
oh
and then he's just cackling away in
there he's dying laughing
my mom was saying she was waiting
we're at this place it was sort of like
a like it was a restaurant like beside
uh like a little outdoor concert that
was going on yeah so there was like a
massive line for the bathroom and there
was two two stalls yeah or like two like
doors basically
my and they were both like you know it's
like guys and girls so my mom's just
like waiting in line she's in the front
of the line yeah and there was just one
door that people were coming out of and
going into the other one was like walked
for a long time
and so she's waiting there she's the
next one in line and this dude goes up
this dude from behind her goes up in
front of her Slams on the door
and then gets back in line behind her
[Laughter]
like the dude
prank it's a really good price
what are you doing what the [__] are you
doing
you're you can go in front of me go in
front of me you can go in front of me no
no you got him no no no you got him no
no you got it man no I can hold the guy
over I can hold it yo this dude
I thought you got out of there man he's
been waiting he's been waiting bro's
been waiting
I haven't been waiting that long he's
lying I didn't I wasn't the one who
knocked dude
thinking about your mom just standing
there just like smiling yeah and then
some [__] dude walks out what is your
problem
is your mom just trying to explain no it
was it wasn't
oh it wasn't me she turns around that
guy's just not there yeah yeah it was
him oh
yes
[__] is so mean but it's so funny
it's so funny it's funny because it also
it works yeah
yeah like have you ever gotten knocked
on before yeah it does it it like
instills a sense of panic I gotta wrap
this up no I'm a bit entitled are you
yeah if they knock on them you're gonna
wait I'm like yep
yeah that's all I do
see I'm the type of guy like if someone
is waiting for a parking spot I'm like I
get out of there as fast as I can I'd do
that okay yeah no but if I'm [__]
I feel like it's the same sort of thing
no taking my time taking your sweet time
yeah I don't want a hemroid man yeah
I've had a hemorrhoid before yeah it was
the worst
it sucked
so itchy
and it's just every poop hurts every
single one
so anyways so
that's why you couldn't enjoy the Drake
concert
in this
seat
isn't it kind of hot in here yeah
38 years old of the Hemorrhoid at a
drake show you gotta prep H in your back
clear bag policy
everything out of your pockets please
that's not everything there's something
else in your pocket no don't make me
don't make me [__] infinite game
it's the little capsules
just a pack of those yeah the [__] are
these earplugs no
sort of
foreign
dum dum dum
yeah yeah that's you with the Drake
concert oh my God your seat donut is
this song 7f okay
ass is like in it
look at that guy tipping his hat
excuse me me lady
I have a hemoroid
[Laughter]
this is more like Frank Sinatra yeah it
depends actually yeah he could be a
neckbeard yeah he could definitely be a
neckbeard did they just fill them with
detail and color he's got like a [__]
Avengers t-shirt on underneath yeah yeah
which is Spider-Man pins on the sport
coat yes
[Laughter]
watch death of the bacon narwhal
I don't even know that's the right meme
it's it's almost there it's close
it's just what does the making narwhal
isn't it or what time
at midnight dude the normal Bacons at
Midnight duh oh [__] it's a catchphrase
I was created for redditors to identify
themselves in public places
so it's like what time does the bacon
narwhal
any other person's supposed to say oh at
midnight oh tip of my cap to you my
brother
good to meet you
can you imagine that in 2012 oh [__]
what subreddits do you mind oh [__]
well I am the uh lead moderator of the
rimworld subreddit yeah in various spots
loaded to uh intern on the amaranth
subreddit anyway should we do the bonus
I guess we should
I guess we should yeah I mean I guess
as we should all right let's hop into it
um do you want to ride this thing yeah
out of the episode let me ride out yeah
you gotta feel the speed of this thing
actually it's it's pretty thrilling
it is
dude and there's like safety Wheels on
the back
[Laughter]
what did he do what did he just hit
I don't know what was that
dude we have to take this thing to Vegas
we have to